i wish for all of you a catastrophic
failure
something that makes you cry that you
just want to sit in a dark closet for
saying
why did i do that how did that happen
the idea that you're going to be
successful in all your endeavors is
complete bs
and the key to that is every time you
fail because there'll be more than once
you have to learn from it you do not
want to do that again
beautiful day for a little hike in the
mountains and i thought it would be just
spectacular
to do another episode of ask mr
wonderful right on top here beautiful
day
i just took a little stroll up the
mountain i thought it'd be
terrific to do this a little fresh air a
little relaxation
but i got a great question here from
robin let me read this to you
hi mr wonderful i'm 25 years old
i'm working in technology i'm wondering
if i could ask you what are the five
things i should be thinking about to be
successful at my age
and tech is not a bad place to be these
days obviously so i'm assuming robin's
got a good job
but let's talk a little bit about the
future
so five things it's a great question
five things
well number one on the hit parade for me
particularly if you're in your mid-20s
is
you've got to have a plan a plan about
investing
in yourself in other words you're
starting your career
you got to start thinking about how much
money am i going to put aside
each week that i'm going to invest for
the long run so when i'm 65 i have my
nest egg
you don't know what life's going to
bring you it's serendipitous anything
can happen you don't know when you're
getting married how many kids you're
going to have whatever
but you got to start in your 20s right
now because it sounds like you got a job
and i don't even care if you don't have
a job
whatever income you've got you've got to
put some aside now the number i like to
throw around all the time
is a hundred dollars take a hundred
dollars each week
and invest it now the good news is
there's all kinds of apps you can use
you can download one you can link it to
your bank account
and you can start saving that's
real important 100 bucks a week if the
market does what it's done
for the last hundred plus years make six
to eight percent in the long run
you're going to end up with a million
and a half bucks in the bank i know that
sounds crazy but it's true
that's kind of what it does when you
start to think about investing
conservatively and compounding all that
interest and dividends and everything
else
so that's number one on the hit parade
think about that
and make that a discipline 100 bucks a
week you know i got to tell you robin
you can do it it's not impossible
all right number two this one's a little
funky chicken
but i've been thinking about it lately
you have to have
some kind of plan you know about
your own self-care routine you got to
think long-term about your body about
what you eat and how you take care of
yourself and the number one thing
for me is your skin your face it's what
people look at every day and if you're
young and you think about this
which means for me moisturizer and
sun protection i've been doing that
forever now i'm doing a plug a shameless
plug for a company that i use
called tiege hanley because they send me
this stuff in a little box which i find
very useful
and i don't have to know how to use it
but the one i'm always using
moisturizer it's good spf 20
protection against the sun very
important check out tiege hanley and get
started for just 25
also they are offering my viewers a
great deal just click the first link in
the description
to get a free toiletry bag with your
first box
you'd be amazed if you just think about
that every day moisturizing and sun
protection
because you know everybody goes outside
you walk somewhere you hang out whatever
you're doing you go cycling you're on
the beach
you're burning you're frying your skin
you're aging yourself prematurely
it's not corny it's smart when you start
doing this early in life you'd be amazed
over the long term how this can help you
so
that's something you should really put
some thought to i like these guys
because i hate perfumey stuff
and you know i've talked about them
before i use them and i don't like to
endorse products that i don't use
so really it's about self-care it's a
routine
number three this is a little more
complicated
in your life you need to find a mentor
someone you can go to that you respect
that you can bounce ideas off because
making your own decisions all the time
you're going to find out without any
kind of feedback you can be wrong
and there's nothing wrong with another
opinion another voice that you can
listen to
that would give you some great advice
now you can change mentors as life
changes as your circumstances change but
you should have one in your life it
could be an older brother could be a
sister could be one of your parents
could be somebody completely random
my first mentor in business was a guy
named jerry patterson
who was actually a lawyer and a hockey
agent
a guy that would bring over russian
hockey players to the original six in
boston philadelphia detroit
i mean how random can that be but he was
really focused about business
he gave me some great lessons in life
and then later in life i turned to my
stepfather george
who was phenomenal in helping me through
building you know some of my businesses
and
the point is was always somebody to go
to
and the great thing about a mentor is
you know you can be completely honest
with them
generally they have your best interests
at hand so that's very important that's
number three
now number four
i have to be sure i put this the right
way
but it's important too is learning how
to fail
i wish for all of you a catastrophic
failure
why there is no lesson in life like
failure
the idea that you're going to be
successful in all your endeavors is
complete bs that never happens for
anybody the most important lessons you
can learn
are from failure why that's the
definition of experience
failing getting up getting back at it
getting back in the race
is what experience is and the key to
that is every time you fail because
it'll be more than once
you have to learn from it you do not
want to do that again
that's the whole idea the more you fail
the better you become because you don't
make those mistakes over again
but i wish for everybody in a good way
now that you understand it a
catastrophic failure something that
makes you cry
that you just want to sit in a dark
closet for saying
why did i do that how did that happen
and then you learn
from it that's absolutely crucial
you know i actually remember sitting in
a dark room thinking about a mistake i
made i think
i i think i was like 15 years old but it
you know these these moments in your
life
really stick and they help you grow all
right
next number five on the hit parade gotta
find a partner in life
it's not as easy as it sounds like i'm
not going to give you marriage advice
here or
or you know whoever you're going to hook
up with your significant other
ends up being very important and they
must be someone that understands you
and you need to understand them because
the the the romantic euphoria that is
the part of the beginning of a
relationship
is spectacular and i've said this many
times i wish that on everybody and some
people
continually fall in love and out of love
just to get that
high of the euphoria of of just the
start of the relationship but that's not
really the challenge
the challenge is staying together not so
easy
and the reason you got to think about
this is staying together is hard but
you're building a foundation of trust
a foundation of perhaps family an
economic foundation
couples that stay together build their
lives together and they have similar
goals financial goals life goals
and that equity becomes very valuable
over time it's not easy
but in your 20s you think about if you
want to have kids you got to start
thinking when you're 25 years old robin
you got to start thinking about okay
how old do i want to be when i have my
first child and look this is a problem
that's been around for people
for for the generations for thousands of
years you got to think ahead
because i one of my great regrets in
life is i didn't get married till i was
36
and i didn't have children you know
until i was 38
i wish i'd had them sooner i wish i'd
made my decision earlier
i can't change that but i'm giving you
advice you asked me for it
i wish i got married a lot earlier and i
wish i'd started having a family a lot
sooner
because i would have enjoyed them even
more and they've to me family is
everything now and you'll find that too
this is advice good bad or ugly it's
your family
and it becomes a big part of your life
and your joys and your sorrows and
everything else
i don't want to get too sentimental here
but you get the timing idea
so if you can find that special person
in your
you know late 20s that ain't a bad thing
that's a good thing and you have to
think more about just
you know the euphoria of romance you got
to think long term is this the right
person to hang with for the rest of my
life
it doesn't work out that way all the
time and some people get married
multiple times
but you wish every time you started one
it would be the one
so the top five number one save ten
percent of your salary invest for the
long term
number two master the art of really
self-care it's an art it's a focus
you take care of yourself it's very very
important find
a mentor always have one during your
life you might change
but find one there's nothing wrong with
that and then of course
fail hard at least once you've got to
fail hard once you
learn so much from it it's so crucial
and lastly and this is a tricky one in
life
gotta find a partner someone that's in
sync with you and hopefully for your
whole life
it'll make it far richer but they've got
to understand who you are they have to
understand you
that's what matters so that's just
some food for thought you know
five things that you really should think
about now
in your mid-20s
it's that easy they're going to be
important today tomorrow
next week but i think it's good advice
now how you deal with it you have to
decide on your own
but i think all of these are things that
i've learned
were very important and even more
important now that i can reflect on them
if you like that video where did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe